[Music]
this week on the masked singer it was a
game of cat and mouse
[Applause]
[Music]
the judges freaked out over the singing
celeb who went home and judge Nicole
Scherzinger is apparently learning all
about nutrition what if he went on a
keto diet I'm just saying only bananas
know they're eyeing carbs we just found
that out plus comedian Gabriel Iglesias
joined the panel and he's just as
confused as we are
this is unmasking the masked singer
Carly did you know that bananas are high
in carbohydrates listen I didn't know
but Nicole certainly did not those abs
are the 8th world wonder of course she
doesn't really know what carbs are the
girl probably never eats a whole lot of
she looks so good exactly
well we have a lot to get into tonight
but first we certainly have an
everlasting love for the first
elimination check it out
[Applause]
iconic R&B hall-of-famer five-time
Grammy Award winner I'm just confused
what we did to deserve so many legends
on season three of the Masters
I mean Chaka Khan in Group A Dionne
Warwick in Group B what a treat for us
as viewers to get to witness her magic
and elegance on the stage were you
surprised I was surprised and they said
five-time Grammy Award winner and she
definitely was a big part of that number
of how many Grammy stats we have the
source but again another legend they're
just keeping it up with booking legends
here yes now look we're gonna call a
spade a spade we sort of predicted this
was Dionne Warwick the clues really led
to that last week let's take it to the
clue package really quick before we get
into tonight's remaining contestants so
the first clue I want to call out is
this Rhino you see it up here on your
screen the Rhino quite simply represents
Rhino Records Dionne Warwick's longtime
record label we also saw an image of
prayer hands so I immediately was like
oh is this someone who's super religious
I do believe Dionne Warwick is a woman
of faith but on like a really fun
surface level the song say a little
prayer for you which we just can never
get out of our heads
take it up cue it up see it up and also
going along with that song we heard we
saw the vanity table actually if we can
put that up as well so her doing her
makeup the lyrics of the song the moment
I wake up before I put on my makeup we
had literally happen in the package work
it MOUs work it's a true delight to have
her on this show but alas we say goodbye
of course the judges they always have
some interesting thoughts and theories
and tonight's first reality check goes
to our pal ken Jeong take a listen to
what he had to say about guessing who
was behind the mouse I think it's a
different legend I think is Tina Turner
I was at a party with Tina Turner and we
were it was a what yes it was there was
a wine and cheese party at a Costco in
the valley
she was my plus-one
why would Tina Turner need you to be a
member the commitment to the joke I
loved I don't know if I love the fabio's
story more or this one a Costco in the
valley salt we just keep counting them
but I do have to point out the judges
we're right about this yeah we heard
them gasp Dionne Warwick and the judges
now I believe it's two masked singers
that they have guessed correctly of
course yeah Jenni and Nicole and Gabriel
all agreed Dionne Warwick so Ken not
Tina Turner maybe the next one
no no Costco no wine no cheese in the
valley Ken and with the mouse gone we do
have four remaining contestants left
and group B we have the Frog banana taco
and the kitty and jumping right into it
our first performer isn't bruised but
certainly has an achy breaky heart check
it out
[Applause]
so last week the banana had us really
stumped but this week I think we're
pretty sold on the banana being Bret
Michaels so I want to get immediately
into the clue package before we start
talking about how incredible this
performance was because those vocals are
there they're first up I want to talk
about this clock so we see this clock on
the on the screen and I'm like sitting
at home to being like a little wannabe
mathematicians writing I'm subtracting
and I'm gonna be honest the timestamp
213 I really couldn't make a whole lot
of I didn't know if it was like a 2 1 3
la area code Bret is not from LA I
really couldn't gather that the thing
that I was honing in on is the 6/8 so
the date is June 8th well June 8th is
national name your poison Day and of
course Bret the frontman of the band
poison so that really kind of to me
makes all the sense in the world the
other clue that I was really sold on was
this black cowboy boot black cowboy
boots that we see him wearing there now
if you know anything about Bret Michaels
he is synonymous with having the most
authentic country look the guy
practically doesn't leave the house
without a cowboy hat I think we have an
image of him if we could throw that up
really quick he's wearing his cowboy
booth there he is he's wearing his
cowboy hat
the signature bandana so I thought that
that was definitely parallel there and
we saw the Hat clue last week yes we
haven't seen a bandana clue yet but I
think when we do next week we can
solidify
yes identity you did speak about poison
we also saw a green snake quickly appear
on a laptop that they turned around it
flashed for a quick second a snake
poison again I think we can figure that
one out for sure we also heard him say
star in your own show on cable during
the clue package they kind of had mock
references to different shows with the
bananas starring in them well Brett has
had a cable reality dating show rock of
love it aired on vh1 and I know it was
your favorite reality show if you
haven't seen it I highly recommend you
try to find it somewhere it is so
delicious and and juicy and there's
romance and there's chaos and Bret is
just such a great television star and I
feel like he's bringing that same
charisma to hopefully that's him on here
on the mast singer so tonight it was a
special night in terms of clues they
asked every single contestant on what
their favorite subject in school was and
for this character I thought it was the
most poignant and the most revealing so
they asked the banana his favorite
subject and he said for me no doubt it
was art it has gotten me through some of
the toughest times in my life and I have
had a few so with Bret Michaels of
course he's a person who's been through
numerous health struggles he he
struggles with with type 1 diabetes and
he suffered a brain hemorrhage that he
actually thought was going to kill him
so pretty serious stuff there I'm
thrilled that he seems to be doing
really well in real life and hopefully
this is him on the mast singer because
the banana is having so much fun that's
a great performance yeah I really like
tonight's a lot well it may only be
Wednesday but the Frog has us hopping to
the club like it's Friday take a look at
the frogs performance
ha Tremec I want this remix I don't know
where we have to get it but I love it if
show tunes and 50 cent had a baby it
would be this remix so let's just
declare right off the bat we're going
with Bow Wow yes we said it last week
we're sticking with it again this week
absolutely Bow Wow let's get right into
the clue package here we saw an image of
a basketball so some people might be
inclined to think this might be an NBA
star well
Bow Wow if you followed his career you
know that he was the star of the 2002
comedy movie like Mike so that makes
sense huh we also saw Bow Wow kind of
who we hope is Bow Wow yeah we saw the
contestant kind of in there typing on a
typewriter while the letters were
highlighted on the typewriter CSI Bow
Wow actually appeared in the CSI
spin-off CSI cyber yes and I've really
enjoyed his acting career just put that
out there yes a multi thread here this
Bow Wow
then we saw an image that was a little
strange it was a $19 price tag
accompanied by a star on the Walk of
Fame so this was very strange to me I
had to do a whole bunch of google
searching but this is what I came up
with
Bow Wow put out an album in 2006 called
the price of fame so that's where I kind
of get the star reference from and if
you do the math he was 19 years old when
that album dropped oh so that's where I
feel like the $19 price tag is the 19 I
was age but also price meant a few
thousand yeah the album definitely was
not price inflation the last one we saw
in his package was toy soldiers so this
was kind of a small clue in there but it
could be a nod to his his collaborations
with Soulja Boy they actually had
dropped a mixtape together yeah they're
close pals and they've worked together
quite a lot so I don't know they could
be a little army men but I'm sticking
with the Soulja Boy and we actually have
reality check of number two of the night
it's two Jenny McCarthy take a look at
who she cast for the Frog based off of
the prints clues there's a basketball so
that makes me think Fresh Prince of
bel-air
right
I think it's alfonso ribeiro fun's over
well don't give it away Alfonso I loved
the Frog playing into the fact that it
could be him but I'm still sticking with
out here
no I'll fawn so did this move quite a
few times when he was on Dancing with
the Stars and this version while good
well gosh he's different
not the same not not the same well our
next performer was more than just okay
so take a look at Mitaka
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this this taco is having so much fun the
dancers having fun the tacos having fun
the audience is having fun and we're
having the margaritas are spinning in
the air let's go ahead and get right
into it like we said last week we were
really confident and we're still super
confident this is Tom Bergeron TV host
sweet man celebrated television star you
know the the big thing for you was
America's Funniest Home Videos right so
I immediately saw the whoopee cushion it
was kind of the first quick clue we saw
there in the package if we can throw
that up a quick nod to a whoopee cushion
in a hard shell taco well as we know I
mentioned it last week Tom Bergeron host
at Hollywood Squares Whoopi Goldberg
Whoopi Goldberg was actually the center
square on Hollywood Squares when Tom was
the host
there you go this also could be nodding
to America's Funniest Home Videos jokes
pranks a whoopee cushion silliness
exactly I love the double meaning there
and then we got to see this disco shaped
ball with a constellation on it so of
course first of all I love anything
sparkly glittery Mirrorball esque of
course if you win Dancing with the Stars
you win the Mirrorball trophy which this
is in the shape of but then the Gemini
constellation I immediately start
thinking Tom's birthday may be his
wife's birthday well it's neither of
those it's actually the Gemini falls on
the day that they got married which
would be May 22nd 1982 yes which is
great then if you're a fan of Dancing
with the Stars like me
we got another clue that I want to tee
up it's the the toupee the hairpiece on
a plate nonetheless it's very very
strange I didn't quite know what to make
of this I know tom has appeared on Harry
Connick Jr's show so quite literally
Harry but I did do some digging and I
found this tweet if we can if we can
throw that up really quickly there's a
tweet that Tom shared this image where
he goes they always let me know when my
hairpiece is slipping and and we see him
there with two of the girls on Dancing
with the Stars kind of helping each
other out so he has talked about hair
pieces before listen I don't think he
has a hairpiece but we've got a
beautiful head of hair I love that salt
and pepper you know he's making a
reference to something that he has also
joked about before yeah let us know if
you have more insight on let us know
also in the clue package we heard
we saw a lady taco first of all a lady a
lady taco come down the stairs he talked
about his love and finding romance in
his life and we also heard a voiceover
that he used to be hot-headed well tom
has spoken openly about this with Dan
Harris from ABC on his podcast 10%
happier all about mental health and Tom
said that he practices meditation now
and it's something he started when he
first married his wife and they were
very vocal about his anger management
issues and this has really helped him
through through his stressful times I
love that and now he's so stress-free
that we think he's on the Matt singer
sockless singing living out his best
dreams
well our final performer of the night
showed us some serious cattitude and we
have thoughts about it take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're allergic to this guy lerczak to
this cat that is right we would like to
claw our way out of this narrative
because this cat is I think in the
history of the show in my opinion this
is the hardest celebrity that we've
tried to guess we've gone through so
many names last week we were really
steadfast on Sabrina carpenter this week
we've got some more clues and we've kind
of put Sabrina to the side and we're now
kind of sold on either Lucy Hale or
Sophia Carson so I'll talk us through
Lucy Hale first and we'll get into why
we think it's her so Lucy Hale this song
that was performed tonight is a country
song and if you're a fan of Lucy Hale
you know that she loves singing country
music in fact she put out an album in
2014 called
Road between it was a full on country
record so that kind of on a very basic
level is someone who is a country fan
and I think sonically the sound of her
voice Lucy's voice sounds like the
Kitty's voice um if we can throw up the
clue package really quick the
sewing-machine that was a huge focus of
tonight's clue package Lucy is the star
of the CW show Katy keen and the show is
really focused around fashion and sewing
and Katy is an aspiring designer and so
that symbolism really seemed to work I
mean look this is actually from Katy it
looks just like the clue pocket exactly
like they had the same crew or the same
set on to film that then we want to talk
about Little Red Riding Hood so once the
Kitty was done whipping up a masterpiece
she whipped up this Red Riding Hood now
I think two things about this number one
there's the Pretty Little Liars tie-in
if you watch Pretty Little Liars red
coats and the whole Little Red Riding
Hood and big bad wolf narrative was like
a huge metaphor throughout the entire
series but also last week's clue package
we saw that Rose shattering on Pretty
Little Liars the name of the town they
lived in was called Rosewood so I don't
know I'm am I right no I think all of
this definitely makes the issue is they
make sense for Sophia as well yeah so we
have multiple people that these clues
are relating to so I'll jump right into
it for Sophia Carson again at the sewing
machine and sketching dresses well
Sophia played Ava on the perfectionist
which is a spin-off of Pretty Little
Liars and her character is an aspiring
fashion designer
right so kind of that same narrative
there and the Little Red Riding Hood
outfit could also be a nod to Pretty
Little Liars it had the recurring theme
with the red hoods like you just
mentioned she's on the spin-off of
Pretty Little Liars still kind of a
storyline there absolutely and bringing
up last week's clue about the Rose
sophia was in descendants the hit Disney
movie that obviously bases a lot around
fairy tales and fables that could be a
nod to anything relating Beauty and the
Beast there she have a photo of her
right there with a rose yeah
so there's a lot pointing I would like
to say though there was one red herring
in this clip I think a red herring
at this point we heard Modern Family's
ball obviously that would make us a
modern dress at like a family's members
at all yes we would think Modern Family
or we're not really going towards that
route anymore no I mean a lot of people
around our office and some of our
friends have figured maybe it could be
Sarah Hyland Kucera is a singer Modern
Family just wrapped up and can actually
guest Sarah Hyland this week he did but
if you follow Sarah on social media
apparently it got back to her that
people think she's on the show and
here's what she had to say on her
Instagram story hey so I'm catching up
on the mast singer and I'm watching I
just will watch the package for kitty
the kitty
Miss Kitty I don't know whatever but I
can really see why you guys think that
it's me because a lot of her clues but I
can relate I can relate and I mean my
nickname in the sixth grade was even
Miss Kitty so I'm kind of freaked out is
there like another is there carbon copy
of me out there in the world because
I've been busy with modern and like I
don't even get to see my friends anymore
or is it me and I'm just dumping you of
listen we're used to celebrities
throwing us I think the best last season
was Patti LaBelle flat-out telling Andy
Cohen it was not her and then Andy
replaying it to her again saying it's
you right so we're used to
Bertie's kind of lying about possibly
being on the show they legally cannot
house what it is they're doing be sued
if they tell us her ID it wouldn't be
fun for you and me to know exactly so I
mean her denying it she seems very
passionate about it not being her and
joking that there could be a carbon copy
of her life out there yeah but again it
could be her it's still it's still a
possibility exactly I want to take a
really quick rewind back to the group a
contestants so week after week Charlie
and I have sat here and we've told you
that we think the kangaroo is Jordan
woods let's take a little quick refresh
and listen
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right so you hear the voice there
we've decoded the clues before et
actually spoke with Jordan last week at
event in Los Angeles where we asked her
about being on the masked singer and she
had this to say
like really that's crazy
no I love that show so much my sister
and I watched it all the time I wish I
could be on that show yeah really
no I actually love the King uh I've been
watching this season but I'm I'm late a
couple episodes so I need to catch up
no I wish excuse me as I sip my tea
acting expert Charlie Oh Keith do you
think that's acting that we just saw or
do you think she's being truthful about
body language the smile smile the
one-word answers Jordan mr. dude we are
on to you I feel like she wasn't really
prepared for that question I think we
caught her in a loop which I'm happy we
did yeah she did a good job she kept it
cool she was like this is something that
my sister and I like watching I wish it
was me but that tone like we just heard
her singing that see a song dude if it's
not Jordan woods who the heck could it
be and listen I hope it is her so we can
play that back again when she does get
on master yes nude or - just like we did
with Miss Patti exactly it was another
wild week of course every Wednesday
Charley and I are here live decoding all
the clues behind the masked singer thank
you for tuning in tweet us your thoughts
and theories we always respond back so
we have - and next week we are gonna see
the champions for group B and we will
get our final three that are moving on
to the super 9 who is that who is that
we'll see you next week goodbye
[Music]